si on rap du chou des carottes des
oignons qu'on y ajoute du vinaigre et
des assaisonnements on a tout pour faire
une choucroute une salade de choux ou du
pique-niz
[Musique]
connais-tu le Pease certains aliments
n'ont même pas besoin de figurer dans
les livres de recettes pour être
populaire c'est le cas du piclize très
tendance sur les réseaux sociaux et dans
toutes les cuisines haïtiennes
si les préparer à base de choux le
pique-niz n'est ninjoucroute ni une
salade de chou la salade de chou est
vraiment c'est pas de la salade de chou
[Musique]
les frères Hakim et abdela Cassia
cherchant une façon de partager leur
fierté pour la culture haïtienne on a
mis leur comptoir caribéen on l'honneur
de cet accompagnement relevé question
facile est-ce qu'on dit là ou là
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire par contre on
peut le traduire
bonne question
c'est un condiment mariné
et à quelle occasion
tu le manges c'est souvent avec la frite
qu'on appelle donc c'est la bouffe de
rue griot plantain des marchands dans la
rue qui savent ça ou souvent dans les
occasions spéciales si on va faire du
griot je sais pas moi pour l'entendre
Noël des bananes pesibles parce qu'il
faut comprendre que ça c'est pas la
bouffe de tous les jours tu sais c'est
vraiment c'est plus qu'on célèbre qu'on
consomme ça
par contre moi perso je mets j'utilise
depuis clé sur tout sur mesure dans les
burgers
[Musique]
on le trouve aux côtés de presque tous
les plats ça ramène tout le temps un
punch quand tu rajoutes ça dans ta
bouchée dans la même famille que le
kimchi coréen la choucroute européenne
et le courtidot du Salvador le
pique-nice peut être préparé par
fermentation ou tout simplement mariner
comme le font les frères acacias tout
simplement ma recette est bien simple
parce que la base c'est l'orange chaud
qui est très importante
si Hakim et Abdel ont grandi à deux
montagnes au Québec c'est un Haïti dans
la cuisine de la grand-mère que ce
dernier a eu la piqûre pour la cuisine
typique du pays pour sa recette
signature il a opté pour une touche non
traditionnelle et colorée tu as du
vinaigre aussi il faut pas trop de
vinaigre parce que le vinaigre c'est un
peu plus fort puis ça monte ça va que
Laurent ça avec Laurent short tu goûtes
Laurence si tu mets juste du vinaigre ça
va goûter le vinaigre avant même que tu
goûtes le reste des ingrédients puis il
est très important le piment ce soit les
piments c'est moi qui viennent de Jamaï
c'est qui sont les scotch bonnet parce
qu'il y a un serveur aussi dans le
piment c'est pas juste forte c'est
vraiment important à savoir du piment
sur une échelle de 1 à 10 de piquant
c'est combien
6.5 l'idée c'est pas de brûler le palais
l'idée c'est vraiment de rajouter un
point je rajouter une saveur de plus de
vraiment compléter la bouchée c'est le
plus petit c'est un mélange de plusieurs
aliments qui pour créer un donc ce qu'on
voulait représenter dans cet exemple là
c'est la Caraïbe donc on représente la
nourriture de plusieurs pays de la
Caraïbes et aussi vous faire un clin
d'oeil à notre à nos origines le bagage
haïtien
crevettes Grillot plantain les
restaurateurs mettent à l'honneur leur
riches héritage culturel un plat à la
fois parce que ça a vraiment commencé
avec la cuisine de mon père qui ont été
plus jeune on a développé
un produit simulant qui est une cuisine
influence iciienne mais moderne donc ça
faisait amplement du sens de se réunir
pour mettre nos forces ensemble pour
passer un restau ensemble
on mélange le chou vert et le saumon
pour donner une couleur plus rosée ça
change pas la ça va mais je pense que
c'est plus agréable ça aussi pour
différencier c'est le resto s'appelle
picliss donc il faut que soit spécial
vous pouvez justement comme vous voyez
j'ai presque le double de chômeur que de
choumou parce que vous voulez que ce
soit trop foncé
là vous voyez quand je mélange je dirais
que ça commence déjà à changer de
couleur vous laisser fermenter au moins
4 heures de temps pour que le piment là
c'est des tours dedans le plus longtemps
qu'on le laisse le plus que il devient
mou puis c'est plus un peu de son aussi
on peut trouver du piclice dans la
section des sauces et des condiments
spécialisés de certaines épiceries c'est
aussi tout simple de le préparer à la
maison
comme obligé de commencer par la poutine
c'est vraiment bon donc tout est là je
trouve le grand qu'on aime dans un
Poutine mais le picclisme amène un petit
fraîcheur le pique de piquant on dirait
que ça balance avec le grand ça vient
exactement ça veut balancer c'est moins
lourd c'est ça va aussi
c'est un bon résultat est-ce que c'est
ton rapport préféré sur le menu j'ai
j'alterne mais j'ai mangé de la poutine
pendant un ange
c'est quoi pour toi c'est un repas qui
manque de fun
commence avec le petit live je suis
d'accord
[Musique]